So I need to warn you -- fair warning, I am
new to this practice of talking about social
policy.
That's because until recently, I was engaged
in implementing social policy.
As the commissioner of New York City's largest
public social services agency, I was responsible
for the day-to-day operation of some of our
nation's biggest antipoverty programs.
At the New York City Human Resources Administration,
we administered everything from cash, welfare,
to food stamp benefits, to Medicaid eligibility,
to child support collections, and a host of
other programs in between.
So my perspective comes from someone who's
seen these programs work day-to-day over a
long period of time.
And what I learned and what I saw was that
government can create an environment whereby
people in poverty can move into work and raise
their incomes.
But it takes adherence to certain core principles.
And those principles are: we must require
work in return for assistance.
We must also reward work by making low wages
go farther.
We must always talk about two-parent families
and the importance of mothers and fathers
in the appropriate raising of children.
And finally, we must be vigilant about promoting
a job-producing, growing economy -- low wage
jobs, middle wage jobs, high wage jobs, providing
opportunity to low income Americans.
Now, I suppose it's possible that you might
be thinking how did I, how did someone like
me get into the poverty fighting world to
begin with.
I mean, look at me.
Frankly, I look kind of Republican even, even
conservative.
And I am.
But I chose to make my career helping struggling
Americans because of what I saw in my father's
career working in the Civil Rights Division
of the United States Justice Department.
He came to Washington on 1960, at the end
of the Eisenhower administration and joined
the Civil Rights Division at that point and
stayed through President Kennedy's administration
and almost to the end of the Johnson administration.
And during that time, he was engaged or involved
in all of the really difficult problems and
conflicts that occurred during that time.
And it was positive and forward looking and
it made our country better.
And ultimately, it was inspiring because it
showed that government and us, Americans,
could improve our country.
And then, at the request of his friend, Robert
Kennedy, we moved to New York City, where
Robert Kennedy had started a small antipoverty
program in Bedford-Stuyvesant, one of the
largest slums in America at the time, a neighborhood
of 500,000 New Yorkers in central Brooklyn.
And my father was involved in a small program
bringing economic development and private
sector investment and some real estate development.
And over his experience there, they made some
small gains for a few people on a few blocks
in Brooklyn.
But meanwhile, larger forces were at work.
Larger forces were at work, and they were
the welfare entitlement state that had said,
as part of the reforms that took place in
the '60s and '70s, we will provide assistance
to people without regard to what they do -- as
a matter of right or a matter of entitlement.
So while a few people were benefited by the
Bedford-Stuyvesant Restoration Corporation,
hundreds of thousands were sucked into a life
of dependency and no work.
And our city was almost brought to its knees.
So when I had a chance to go to work in the
government, I had those two things in my mind:
success and civil rights, not really success
in poverty.
And so I joined the Pataki administration
in 1995, luckily right at the beginning of
the welfare reform movement in America.
Governor Engler, Governor Thompson, Bill Clinton,
Newt Gingrich decided to change welfare as
we know it.
And I worked there for Governor Pataki and
then for Mayor Giuliani for that entire period.
And what did we do?
We required work in return for public assistance.
We made it a clear expectation that it was
a reciprocal relationship between the receiver
of assistance and the provider of aid.
In that regard, we changed the names of our
offices.
They used to be called -- think of this, the
welfare offices in New York City used to be
called Income Maintenance Centers.
Income Maintenance Centers.
We changed them to be Job Centers.
We paid people that tried to help people get
jobs only if they got jobs.
We paid for performance.
We talked about child support enforcement.
We said children need two parents contributing.
There's a responsibility for both parents
to care for their children.
And we created an environment where if there
wasn't a job or someone couldn't work, we
said to them, well, we need you to be involved
in the schedule and rigor on a day-to-day
basis of something that looks like a job.
We'll provide assistance, but we need you
to be in a circumstance where you're mirroring
the schedule and rigor of employment.
So that's the tough stuff.
We also rewarded work.
So public health insurance for low wage workers,
we were generous with it.
Food Stamp benefits for working people, we
provided it.
Childcare assistance, the Earned Income Tax
Credit -- we promoted these supports for low
wage workers, so wages could go further.
We talked about family.
We promoted two-parent families.
And always, always we understood that in order
to succeed at its best we needed a thriving
job producing economy.
And we didn't make any disparagements about
dead-end jobs or low wage jobs.
We said we need jobs.
Any job is a step up.
So we promoted hospitality and restaurants
and health care.
And every time I saw those economic development
guys in the halls of government, I said, make
it happen.
We need jobs.
Require work, reward work, talk about family,
promote a strong economy.
Those are the four principles of success in
this endeavor.
So what happened?
Where were the statistics?
So everyone knows welfare caseloads plummeted.
The peak welfare caseload in New York City
was 1.1 million cash welfare recipients.
One in seven New Yorkers was receiving the
dole.
Recently, last year, before I left, we were
down to 350,000 out of a city of more than
8 million.
Tremendous decline, but that wasn't our greatest
achievement.
Our greatest achievement was work rates for
never-married mothers.
Work rates for never-married mothers.
The very people who were on cash welfare in
the first place, the very people who the program
was originally set up to help.
It went from 43 percent to 63 percent -- a
20 percent point increase, unprecedented and
remarkable and it happened all across the
country, not only in New York City.
Child poverty in New York City declined dramatically
in the late '90s up into the 2000s, from 43
percent to 28 percent -- significant decline
in child poverty.
And what was the most compelling statistic
of all?
And this is a national statistic.
African-American child poverty in the United
States dropped from 44 percent in 1994 to
30 percent in 2008 -- 2001, excuse me.
Now, think of that.
Almost half African-American children were
in poverty before welfare reform, less than
a third after welfare reform.
Now, since the early 2000s, I have to say,
I'm not sure we've kept focused on those core
principles.
We've gotten away from the required work requirements.
We've made rewarding work sometimes replace
work, so that some of the benefits we provide
provide disincentives to people being in work.
We haven't talked about the importance of
two-parent families enough.
And most egregiously, we've allowed our economy
to not grow.
The greatest tragedy of the anemic recovery
we have been through these last five years
is the damage it's done to poor Americans.
So from someone who's been in the business,
who's seen it work successfully and seen it
maybe not work so successfully, require work,
reward work, talk about family, promote a
strong economy.
Those are the keys.
Now, I have one last point I want to make
and this is an important one.
It is a common desire to promise an outcome,
to guarantee that we will -- if we do this,
we will guarantee people's rising safely into
the middle class.
Governments can't promise that.
They can't guarantee that.
People make that happen.
People make that happen if the environment
is created for that to happen.
So to promise an outcome of that kind, to
guarantee it as if it would -- as if government
could provide it, it's a false promise and
it's a harmful promise.
But if we create an environment whereby people
in poverty can move into work and increase
their incomes.
You know what?
They'll do it.
They did it before.
They proved all of the commentators and all
of the prognosticators wrong about what would
happen if we went to a work-based welfare
program.
They were the heroes of welfare reform.
And we need to get back to that kind of policy
to help poor Americans in the future.
Thank you very much.
Thanks for watching.
We'd like to know what you think about fighting
poverty, so tell us in the comments below.
Then please help us spread the word by sharing
this video.
For more vision talks click the subscribe
button and visit the website ThePursuitOfHappiness.com.